um last minute training for election
staff in Yangon Myanmar is biggest city
officials from the Election Commissioner
explaining to the participants what
their job is on Election Day for many
here this is all completely new Myanmar
hasn't had anything close to nationwide
free elections for 25 years me when I'm
look Eliza oh yeah what the authorities
asked for my help and I felt it's my
obligation as a citizen of Myanmar at
this historic moment that is why I'm
doing this y OV da da da da Vinci Luton
a droid army or any power generator blow
the participants here were carefully
chosen by the Election Commission they
have to be at least 18 years of age and
be able to speak read and write Burmese
been highlighted on all the election
staff are free from political
affiliations don't take part in
political activities horny they don't
support any of the parties when they're
trying to work towards as free and fair
elections as they can colima demuccio
tono sama dama bell i moved engineer but
there are still many concerns as to how
free and fair this ballot will actually
be in the run-up to these elections
especially opposition leader Aung San su
Qi has repeatedly warned of fraud and
indeed there have been widespread
problems with inaccurate voter lists and
critics have warned advanced voting
procedures for example for members of
the armed forces are prone to vote
rigging the EU has sent 150 election
observers we've already found out too
early voting stations all over the
country but some places are off limits
even for them let's get there between
four and five hundred thousand army
members who've always had their barracks
we don't have access to that from an
observers point of view of course who
would like to be able to monitor as much
as possible from what they have seen so
far they say they haven't encountered
any irregularities but the real test
will be on election day when Myanmar's
more than 30 million voters will get
their turn at the ballot boxes